scusate ok
noi sogniamo abbiamo scelto di sognare
perché siamo fatti per sognare e non si
usa più parlare di amore bisogno di
credere a qualcosa
noi invece cerchiamo sempre ogni giorno
io dico sempre appena apriamo gli occhi
ci svegliamo apriamo gli occhi e
cominciamo a sognare
cominciamo a sognare di poter cambiare
lo stato delle cose di poter creare
nuova economia
naturalmente siamo arrivati ad un punto
che è troppo bello e troppo emozionante
vi racconterò che cosa abbiamo
realizzato però è necessario che io vi
dica prima che cosa facevo quindi nella
mia prima vita sino al 2004 quindi la
mia prima vita è stata una vita comoda
ha già tissima piena di soldi di
gioielli l'ho messo qui per ricordarmi
di dirvi per me ormai un lontano ricordo
però ho buttato tutti i gemelli delle
camicie tutte le camicie cifrate tutte
le collane di perle tutti gli abiti che
si usano quando sei una top manager e 6
all'apice della carriera perché in
realtà io ho realizzato il primo modello
di banca virtuale in italia mi sono
inventata degli strumenti di lavoro
comodi per gli impiegati per i clienti
per i clienti fisici e virtuali
volevo rendere facile la vita delle
persone
forse una dote non lo so però o
automatizzato tutti i processi di
routine che esistono in una banca l'ho
fatto con tanta fatica e ci siamo
ritrovati la prima banca multicanale
online
a quel punto all'apice della carriera
come si diceva prima nel 2004 ho avuto
un po di disagio nel senso che non
volevo stare più nella stanza dei
bottoni avevo dimostrato che sapevo fare
le cose che potevo creare innovazione
tecnologica e percepivo come si diceva
prima la percezione del cambiamento
percepivo una crisi
è una povertà intellettuale una crisi
economica una crisi di valori che era
necessario per forza rivedere il modello
ricostruire qualcosa e ho cercato di
capire come poter fare qualcosa come
poter dare le mie competenze non sono
competenze
chissà quali competenze io sono
coraggioso tenace ostinata non mollo
sino a quando non raggiunga l'obiettivo
è quello significa sognare realizzare il
sogno significa non mollare mai e così
ho pensato ma cosa mi piace fare forse
mi piace a mare
forse mi piace voler bene e dare ed armi
ho pensato che la nuova frontiera della
ricchezza in quel momento di crisi fosse
dare e darsi e a quel punto dopo un
viaggio che si è detto prima in brasile
dove vedevo gli occhi il sorriso dei
bambini lo sguardo che cambiava se c'era
o non c'eri
l'intervento come possiamo cambiare lo
stato delle cose
ho visto questi bambini lui che
indossava i miei occhiali e io dicevo
non è possibile dobbiamo fare qualcosa
per loro perché nella stanza dei bottoni
si si cambiano le cose ma non si
cambiano stando tra la folla bisognava
capire io volevo capire quali fossero i
bisogni e allora dall'innovazione
tecnologica
ho pensato lavoriamo sull'innovazione
sociale quali sono i luoghi più
degradati dove c'è più bisogno di aiuto
e allora sono entrata in un contesto
pieno di disagio nel carcere dove ho
messo in piedi un laboratorio sartoriale
o anche brevettato un collo di camicia
però sono uscite tutte con l'indulto
dopo sei mesi di formazione e allora ho
capito che non era non era vero allora
scelto delle cose molto più semplici
però nell'innovazione io cosa ho pensato
usiamo il buon senso cosa c'è oggi che
viene abbandonato viene allontanato da
una porta e ci sono le persone gli
esseri umani
la carne il sangue le persone che sono
chiuse in un carcere in una cella
dicevamo ieri forse questo questo
cerchio non basta però la cella
tre passi per 2 3 1 e 2 proprio come
questo cerchio proprio questo cerchio ci
sono due lettini un tavolino e due sedie
o stai seduta o stai in piedi in due in
piedi non si può stare in una cella a
quel punto ho pensato ma 20 ore chiuse
così donne o uomini donne per 78 anni
cosa faranno quando escono quale sarà il
loro stato d'animo e allora ho pensato
se insegno a cucire e a lavorare
restituisco o dono la dignità la dignità
di essere umano
allora ho cominciato a raccogliere dei
tessuti che rimanevano inutilizzati nei
magazzini
ho preso queste donne gli ho insegnato
io non so cucire però ho insegnato mi
piace disegnare però ho insegnato a
cucire e facciamo package e normale
borse per la spesa borse per i convegni
la personalizzazione con il logo delle
aziende che sponsorizzano questa
iniziativa quindi ho pensato ecco come
fare un buon uso del mondo
ecco come poter cambiare generare
cambiamento come facciamo prodotti
semplici piacciono a tutti questi
braccialetti che si diceva prima io sono
più i gemelli non ho più le collane o
questi braccialetti delle collane che si
fanno con dei tessuti che sono belli
sono colorati proprio perché il nostro
progetto vuole trasferire ironia colore
gioia di vivere
non abbiamo voglia di non sono io una
crocerossina non abbiamo voglia di
stimolare beneficenza o commiserazione
noi vogliamo creare un'impresa sociale
che genera benessere genera una
ricchezza economica perché comunque si
producono delle borse e degli accessori
però con dignità con la possibilità di
dare a queste donne un riscatto
la detenzione femminile secondo me non
azzeccate molto però
sentiamo secondo è la percentuale di
donne in un carcere in italia qual è 15
10 22 40 30 sotto il 50 sotto il 5 per
cento le donne non commettono reato le
donne sono complici perché si sono
fidate perché magari hanno detto tieni
questa borsa lasciata lì sotto ma cos'è
tu non ti preoccupare lasciata di sotto
e io chiedo la donna ma fidati di me io
l'ultima volta che mi sono fidata mi
hanno dato sette anni oppure io dico
parla dimmi chi è stato io
per non parlare non dire sto qui per
sette anni e si fanno la galera in
questo modo quindi diciamo che la donna
tendenzialmente non commette reati certo
né quando lo fa lo fa in maniera io non
conosco i reati non voglio conoscere
reati delle ragazze perché altrimenti
giudico siamo abituati a giudicare e noi
invece cerchiamo solo compagni di
viaggio quindi per tornare ai nostri
prodotti che sono la cosa bella noi
abbiamo i prodotti che non sono prodotti
sono progetti di vita perché utilizzando
il materiale di scarto la seta la pelle
la lycra tutti questi prodotti che
vengono abbandonati noi li facciamo
rivivere con queste donne che imparano
ad avere l'amore per il bello l'amore
per la dignità del lavoro e così
trasferiscono anche figli questo
concetto noi nella nell'innovazione sia
sociale che è distributiva ci siamo
inventati il distributore automatico
perché secondo noi la solidarietà deve
avere un gesto automatico devi mettere
un euro 3 euro 5 euro e 6 partecipe di
un progetto di con una nuova filosofia
con un nuovo stile di vita
la voglia di cambiamento nasce dal basso
ma nasce anche da piccoli gesti
automatici perché noi siamo abituati
invece ad essere sempre ripetitivi
io ho scelto di eliminare tutte le
sovrastrutture che avevo
avevo come anche voglio dire un certo
tipo di vita deve anche avere un format
modo io ho sconvolto tutto non mi
ricordo più niente
mi sembra di essere now 53 anni ma mi
sembra di essere nata dieci anni fa si
ricostruisce bisogna essere pronti al
cambiamento e la cosa bella è che tenevo
a in questo progetto a dimostrare che
funziona funziona perché si è creata un
economia tale da poter far lavorare
tantissime donne tantissime anche uomini
tantissime donne in tutta italia
noi siamo partiti con il carcere di
lecce e trani
però adesso stiamo evolvendo la stampa è
con noi ci segue la stampa la
televisione i social i social network
addirittura il papa il papa siamo
riusciti a mettere il braccialetto al
papa a poggio reale
lui ha indossato il nostro braccialetto
insieme a tante altre persone che
credono in questo progetto ed è la cosa
più bella non sentirsi soli quando si
genera cambiamento e quando si diceva
prima in quel quello specie precedente
quando si contamina quando io sento
percepisco che tutti sono felici possa
avere un braccialetto dove sta il
braccetto si percepisce che vogliono
essere protagonisti del cambiamento con
orgoglio e con dignità per queste donne
che lavorano
il modello è un modello semplice
raccogliamo i tessuti li cataloghiamo
l'italiano li facciamo cucina nelle
carceri e poi vendiamo il prodotto
questa cosa è una cosa che è cresciuta
nel carcere non è più soltanto in puglia
a lecce e trani
noi ci facciamo tanti altri progetti in
particolare questo progetto con il
ministero della giustizia ci ha
consentito di formare donne e acquistare
macchine da cucire in altri
complessivamente 15 carceri italiani
questo significa che quando noi ci è
capitato di vendere 409 mila
braccialetti venduti in tre giorni sono
stati realizzati in tutta italia quindi
noi abbiamo girato per formare per
costruire le competenze per queste donne
quindi è un progetto che ha avuto
tantissimo successo e sta crescendo
grazie a questo progetto abbiamo anche
fatto anche di progetti sempre sfidanti
sempre quasi impossibili perché era
questa la cosa che ci piaceva e abbiamo
chiamato convocato delle donne vittime
di tratta e di sfruttamento giù in
carcere a lecce da venezia infatti il
progetto si chiama lecce venezia andata
e ritorno
queste donne sono venute da noi in
carcere le vittime sono andate ad
imparare dalle donne che avevano
commesso reati
ci sono diciamo contaminate fra di loro
hanno imparato un mestiere con la
biennale di venezia con il comune di
venezia abbiamo creato dei prodotti e le
ragazze sono tornate a venezia hanno
aperto un laboratorio quindi noi abbiamo
generato altraeconomia la cosa più bella
qui c'è giovanni lo storto questa cosa
che si è inventata di far lavorare
l'estate i ragazzi gli studenti in
contesti di disagio perché capissero e
vedessero e toccassero con mano che
cos'è la vita vera infatti prima dicevo
questa non è un'università e una umani
universitet perché impara i ragazzi
imparano a confrontarsi con la realtà
non la realtà virtuale e quindi vengono
a fare dei tirocini estivi giù da noi in
carcere l'altra cosa bellissima e che
secondo noi
si parlava prima di bisogni latenti
bisogni percepiti e latenti io credo
dopo questo progetto nel mondo del
tessile che sia necessario riconciliarsi
con la natura
e così abbiamo donato dei degli orti
verticali nelle carceri nei maschili
dove loro percepiscono il profumo il
ritmo della terra della natura mettere
le mani nella terra sia gli studenti
perché l'abbiamo coinvolto anche abbiamo
coinvolto anche degli studenti sia
studenti che uomini detenuti lavorano la
terra e ritornano a conoscere il ritmo
della natura perché non c'è un
telecomando che ti fa crescere le
fragole non c'è un fertilizzante che
all'improvviso fa venire fuori un
basilico con foglie così bisogna
necessariamente riconciliarsi perché
sennò va a finire male
non c'è in italia ancora una misurazione
dell'impatto sociale che questo progetto
sta procurando è importante sapere che
c'è un seguito nel senso che la
possibilità di replicare su scala questo
progetto è facilissimo perché ci vuole
poco il lavoro è fatto con cuciture
dritte il non ci vogliono non ci
vogliono molti mesi per diventare
competenti quindi l'idea è quella di
cominciare a misurare l'impatto
ambientale e sociale che questo progetto
determina perché anche i figli dei figli
spezzano la catena del destino che una
donna una detenuta è rassegnata e
condannata a replicare con la famiglia
invece così l'autonomia economica
consente di sostenere costi per la
famiglia non essere un peso
l'apparecchio bambini libri la festa
della prima comunione
e questo quello che io ho voglia di
trasferirvi si può fare
c'è un piccolo video che adesso vi
faccio vi faranno vedere è un
solo la sintesi è quello che mi viene
restituito io faccio volontariato da
sette anni per scelta perché ho scelto
una vita frugale semplice come dice il
giogo di nòverca il mio manuale
preferito perché mi ritrovo perché la
vita non è fatta sempre di
sovrastrutture io le ho provate sono
belle ma preferisco essere povera grazie
in un luogo dove tutto viene privato
abbracciarsi e come se fosse un senso di
liberazione
noi possiamo abbracciarci perché
crediamo reciprocamente nella
possibilità di cambiare gli scenari
della vita
no